aicon 25 ciao a tutti benvenuti sono i
veri sanità siamo un miglio topolino
zoccoli oggi devo vedere gli smartphone
più assurdi più fighi più strani al
mondo siete pronti lasciate un bel like
consigliate sia anche altre cose assurde
da vedere nei commenti prende di pop
corn 19100 schermo è iniziamo 01 e tutto
stiamo un telefono che si piega ma
voglio
sì questa è la sums l'anno recentemente
presentato qualcosa del genere però è
solo una presentazione di prototipo è
tipo questo ma è fighissimo
l'hanno fatto ancora vedere bene l'anno
dopo ho fatto vedere un pochettino così
che si sta quindi però hanno costituito
non vedo l'ora di provarlo sia sempre
una cosa dico trasforma per questo
facciamo perché lo metti stato quello
altri diventa più grande quando il
telefono il lenovo plastico che cos'è un
iphone allungato e con 25
proprio lungo nostra telecomando piazza
e proprio cosa che si piega tipo
bracciolo allora si sia una funzionalità
così è figo ce lo spieghi sul braccio
metti addosso
wow diventa così diventò un bracciale a
supersano vedere intel e forse questo mi
piace non so se poi lo utilizzerei però
episodi mentre di dare i voti allora
quello di prima che si piega in dieci
perché sarebbe fighissimo salirò un otto
e mezzo perché non so per quanto sarebbe
comodo sul morso tu che vota gli dai
anche secondo me il primo per dieci ci
sta questo qui invece un pochettino di
mano io direi set perché rimane troppo
grosso sul bravo che cosa gli date da
110 iscrivetevi con vedo l'ora telefono
numero 3
forse anche questo è un telefono animi
aurea il tastierino sotto questo mi
sembra molto al mio tanto di giocare
così tipo low sweet si piega proprio
tipo cornetta del telefono di casa
in effetti questo non mi piace ho tanto
sembra un po un telefono addirittura una
tastiera intero era semmai il mac flip
phone la mecca facciata italia fa
messapico di anni fa ricordo scusa tipo
sì ma come ha fatto a tipo tre schermi
nuovo brano fosse effettivamente comodo
è bello dalle tre schermi ma non so se è
comodo fa invece di muovere lo schermo
come lo metti in tasca perché si possa
piegare assist scusa mi puoi anche
collegare due
questo pero ha trascinato tipo
interessante questa strana con lo aprì
non so se guarda così tu persone
possiamo fare lo schermo da non parte da
dall'altra tempo fà solo danno come moto
da concerto e si stavano già abbiamo un
altro samsung pieghevole questo è
stranissimo sembra un foglio fa essere
così sottile a su persone non solo
quando recato che ripiegano sembra
cristiano rompendo perché uno schermo
flessibile ma che fino a questo la
tecnologia in sviluppato samsung se
dello schermo pieghevole mi piacerebbe
avere un foglio enorme questi c'è un
foglio lo schermo foglio enorme che tra
stravotato mettono sul braccio sul
braccio tutto questo è un braccio
bionico sa anche lui sin torino asti me
lo dica ora quel che peccato che non lo
faranno più hanno magari lo faranno in
futuro hanno deciso di abbandonare il
progetto perché questo era un progetto
molto intelligente potevi avere lo
smartphone modulabile quindi cambiato in
modo dei tipo avrei bisogno di uno
schermo nuovo non dovevi sostituire
tutto il telefono sostituito il tifo
così dobbiamo aumentare la ram
volete una fotocamera differente la
potevi mettere l'idea era molto bella
però purtroppo non sono riusciti
magari nel futuro rifarà si spera per
un'ottima idea secondo ma che strano che
lo smonti così come mattoncino di lego e
poi l'attacchi 30 davvero bello in
realtà esteticamente non mi piace molto
un po bruttino via telefono o
un altro doppio schermo o meno vertigo
ora mi dispiace che la apple non sta
ancora facendo questa sera con il doppio
schermo che si aprono perché la regata
diventa di punta blair e la fai anche
appoggiare così stanno iniziando a
creare questi telefoni doppio schermo
cosa ne pensate voi secondo voi è utile
avere due schermi o può essere utile se
ci vuoi fare una foto dall'altra camera
che prende meglio per la camera da
dietro prende meglio puoi vederti invece
di farla con quella frontale è giusto
che questo è sottilissimo sembra finto
sembra un pezzo di gatti libero come
possibile è una sorta di orologio
elettronico
sembra un pezzo di questo è sicuramente
comodo lo puoi mettere in tasca in un
libro ovunque con tranquillità massimo
ecco mobius vediamo come posso tenere
lardo tipo l'anno beh lui mentre i pezzi
che vuoi
marino ha molta mattina qualche anno da
sabato anche come
designer più bello si è procurato uno
zio che strano pratica tipo sembra con
un prisma a te le forme solissimo io
penso che questo blackberry qua non
siamo molto comodo questo forse sì voi
cosa ne pensate
poi il cognato questo qui su questo
blackberry è vero non fa niente
precisamente chiama e basta il telefono
della ferrari e brutti ma non mi piace
per niente voi piace ma questo è un
quadrato ma è già uscito già era
qualcosa di vecchio forse sì secondo me
sì questo in cina è stata vinta insieme
una mia amica che ha vietato in cina è
tornata come un telefono tipo fatto a
forma di come si chiama quello per
mettere il trucco siria sia forme
delitto forma di cipria ma sembrava
veramente per restare un telefono è
perfetto puoi fare lo spionaggio
va da un momento incipriarmi il naso
invece ricordo male funziona va
malissimo però all'appello perché era
super piccolino dello sportello di
mettere in tasca l'anno sentirmi nemmeno
questo telefono qua non mi piace proprio
telefono quadrata voi cosa ne pensate
mahmuti ma io non so perchè ma mi
ricordo di averlo già visto questo
telefono quindi fosse uscito anche in
italia
tantissimi anni fa simile non così voi
cosa ne pensate riuscirete ma io sono
telefono del prossimo questo è uscito
non si seguono e cesaria ma non mi
voglio averlo già visto of youtube un
pochino se vi rendete conto che adesso
abbiamo gli smartphone che più o meno si
somigliano un po tutti ma prima saranno
talmente tante forme e tanta tv
smartphone non ero proprio mano se
questo è terribile lunghissimo in
pratica tutto zirafi un coltellino
striscioni
la tua arma di difesa diventa ancora più
lungo erano comodi perché a me non
trovano tutti in tasca per telefonare di
polla lunga ombra corrotta provocano una
console ragazzi voi siete giovani
giovani giovani non l'avete mai visto
quello del telefono
ma chi è giovane più o meno come noi e
conosce questo telefono chi e meno
giovani dei commenti se avete mai visto
questo telefono dal vivo comunque andava
molto di moda tra l'altro la storia come
adesso può essere l'iphone tenno il
samsung 96 adesso samsung e se non verso
al tempo questo nokia era il top cielo
savi così sembra un game boy advance più
piccolo e più grosso ancora mi chiedo
come è possibile
sicuramente tra tipo dieci anni o di più
ma che sandri riguarderemo l'iphone
tendere diremo piedi come faceva notare
quella cosa orribile esonero adesso c'è
questo no che terribile chiamati come lo
mettevi di lucoli così in orizzontale o
verticale
sai che non lo so forse dall'altra parte
è perché non si vede ben mannaggia è un
telefono forma di specchio da
principessa allora esteticamente carino
dare al principe il colore carino
diciamo sempre
ci stiamo tirando le orecchie a per
fitch sembra tipo un costo di sailor
moon
però no decisamente no voi cosa ne
pensate
certo è una cover per telefono avviate a
presenti fa da spazzola lo specchio e da
telefono della spazzola rimangono i
cappelli sono tutti i capelli nel tempo
e non lo so non mi piace questa cover
poi cosa ne pensate ma ovviamente come
può la messa si temono di allora dei
detersivi patiti di hello kitty e no
terribile c'è pure la forma del telefono
e di hello kitty non so che non piace e
voi cosa ne pensate quale anche il
pulsante l'ora preso telefono telefono
film lo spinner pezzo perché lo stacco
mi sono tanto qua e il pulsante al
centro per farlo girare no sembra vero
uguale allo schermo sembra proprio che
funzioni sicuramente un telefono molto
semplice potrei andare su youtube con
questo telefono però ti fa anche da fece
scrivere ma questo piace l'idea
ma è sopra c'è scritto domanda veloce
perché esiste questa cosa lacatus e voi
siamo ora il mouse e ogni tanto dice a
una chiamata urgente altri mouse è
pietro 24 bellissime loray cambiato
corato dopo aver strisciato pur sono 24
le orecchie se questa cosa abbiamo un
telefono trasparente qua vetro che in
realtà abbiamo visto un video samsung
sta realizzando dei televisori
trasparenti
quindi forse fra qualche anno arriva la
iot radiofonici ci sarà il telefono
trasparente quindi è possibile ma quello
sulla mano ce l'ha ma questo penso che
sia una sorta di proiettore vedi già
questo aggeggio qua che proietta i
numeri qua
altre immagini ci vedremo tutti quanti
così col palmo della mano scrive a
scrivere direttamente dal palmo della
mano
tc che spetta la nostra sta mandando a
whatsapp massimo il telefono un telefono
che puoi riempire tipo calcola il
telefono borraccia
capisco il motivo
vabbè si sono i numeri davanti allo
schermo ma non capisco forse quando vai
a correre o meno sale da bere però non
lavora col no un nokia tamarrissimo
dovranno
a seguito di questo colore no di questo
colore blu però era molto simile a
questo quello che voglio
ma la forbice tra la però forse tra
dieci anni vedremo l'iphone dorato
perché stava in fondo rate diremo addio
già prima di no però la forma di questo
telefono estranei stavolta che anap anzi
sembra che ha mangiato troppo e alla
pancia nella molto simile a quello che
avevo io tanto tanto tempo farà bene sì
perché dai tasti cerchio che in realtà
era aveva il navigatore incluso quindi
mi trovavo bene quando avevo appena
preso la patente quindi riuscivo
riuscivo a conoscere tutte le strade di
roma alle 10 è un po più carino stesso
me lo ricordo perché lo facevano anche
rosa e nera rosa bianco è molto carino
perché aveva tutte queste decorazioni
floreali era molto molto bene
più che io forse perché se anche il
marrone l'arancione vicari non voglio
fare pensato questo telefono ma è la
chiave per la lamborghini 8 ratio all
aborto
in pratica è la chiave per la borsa
ovviamente se compri nápoles mica ti
danno una chiave normale tutti danno
macchiate il telefono così se perdi la
macchina chiami chi chiami richiamo a
china
buona idea che mangiate risponde non lo
so
l'eroe lotto primo telefono facciamo
vedere facciamo vedere ma non mi ricordo
il nome era un telefono che morì evitato
ovviamente da mia mamma mi sembra olino
e arancione forse sassoni era qualcosa
del genere e diciamo how tecnologico al
tempo era già passato quando l'ho
ereditato per sparare e poi si ereditano
i telefoni java esattezza il mio primo
in assoluto quello ereditato quello che
ho comprato io quello ereditato forse
famosi bellissimo dove sarà questo no
spesso all'estero farsi una leggenda
dietro questo telefono dovete sapere se
voi siete più giovincelli non sapete ma
questo telefono è e dei frutti e belen
si rompevano per i miei amici lo tirava
ringhiera lo tirava giù dal terzo piano
non si rompe ma mai la fattoria
appetibile la batteria dura vate in pro
due settimane nodi più ove non c'erano i
colori interessato però questi telefoni
indistruttibile giochino snake che
poteri che questo è stato il mio secondo
parliamo di natale
il telefono in distrutti da brevi
commenti quale è stato il nostro primo
telefono oppure se dovete rubarlo ai
genitori hanno raffrontarlo ci siamo
passati anche noi
fateci sapere che altre reazioni volete
vedere in questo canale dal sette un bel
nike per vedere altre cose strane e ora
vi lasciamo 4 caselline sacrificare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite